[Music]
when i was president of the american
psychological association they tried to
media train me
and they an encounter i had with cnn
summarizes
what i'm going to be talking about today
which is the 11th reason to be
optimistic the
editor of discover told us uh 10 of them
i'm going to give you the 11th
so they came to me cnn and they said
professor seligman
would you tell us about the the state of
psychology today we'd like to interview
you about that and i said
great he said but this is cnn so you
only
get a sound bite
so well how many words do i get
i said well one
the cameras rolled and she said
professor seligman what is the state of
psychology today
good
cut cut uh that won't do um
uh
we'd really better give you a longer
sound bite well how many words do i get
this time well you get two
dr seligman what is the state of
psychology today
not good
uh uh uh look dr sullivan we can see
you're really not comfortable in this
medium uh we'd better uh give you a real
sound bite this time you can have three
words
professor seligman what is the state of
psychology today
not good enough
and that's what i'm going to be talking
about i i want to say
why psychology was good why it was not
good and how it
may become
in the next 10 years good enough
and by parallel summary i want to say
the same thing about technology about
entertainment and design because i think
the issues are very similar
so why was psychology good
well for more than 60 years psychology
worked within the disease model uh 10
years ago when i was on an airplane and
i introduced myself to my seat mate and
told them what i did they'd move away
from me
and because quite rightly they were
saying psychology is about finding
what's wrong with you
spot the loony and now when i tell
people what i do
uh they move toward me
and what was good
uh about
psychology about the 30 billion dollar
investment in imh made about working in
the disease model about what you mean by
psychology
is that it 60 years ago
none of the disorders were treatable it
was entirely smoke and mirrors and now
14 of the disorders are treatable two of
them actually curable
and the other
thing that happened is that a science
developed a science of mental illness
that we found out that we could
take fuzzy concepts
like
depression alcoholism and measure them
with rigor
that we could create a classification of
the mental illnesses
that we could
understand the causality of the mental
illnesses we could
look across time at the same people
people for example who are genetically
vulnerable to schizophrenia
and
ask what the contribution of mothering
of genetics are and we could isolate
third variables by doing experiments on
the mental illnesses
and
best of all we were able in the last 50
years to invent
drug treatments and psychological
[Music]
and then we were able to
test them rigorously in random
assignment placebo controlled designs
throw out the things that didn't work
keep the things that actively did
and the conclusion of that
is that psychology and psychiatry of the
last 60 years can actually claim that we
can make
miserable people less miserable
and i think that's terrific
i'm proud of it
um
but what was not good the consequences
of that
were three things the first was moral
that psychologists and psychiatrists
became victimologists pathologizers that
our view of human nature was that if you
were in trouble bricks fell on you and
we forgot that people made choices and
decisions we forgot responsibility that
was the first cost
the second cost was that we forgot about
you people
we forgot about improving
normal lives we forgot about a mission
to make
uh
relatively untroubled people happier
more fulfilled more productive and
genius high talent became a dirty word
no one works on that
and the third problem about the disease
model
is in our rush to do something about
people in trouble
in our rush to do something about
repairing damage
we never occurred to us to develop
interventions to make people happier
positive interventions
so that was not good and so that's what
led uh
people like nancy adkoff dan gilbert
mike chick sent my behind myself to work
in something i call positive psychology
which has three aims
the first
is that psychology
should be just as concerned with human
strength as it is with weakness
it should be
just as concerned with building strength
as with repairing damage it should be
interested in the best things in life
and it should be just as concerned with
making the lives of normal people
fulfilling
and
with genius with nurturing high talent
so
in the last 10 years and the hope for
the future we've seen the beginnings of
a science of positive psychology a
science of what makes life worth living
it turns out that we can
measure
different forms of happiness and any of
you
for free can go to that website and take
the entire panoply of tests of happiness
you can ask how do you stack up for
positive emotion for meaning for flow
against literally tens of thousands of
other people we we created the opposite
of the diagnostic manual of the
insanities a classification of the
strengths and virtues that looks at the
sex ratio how they're defined how to
diagnose them what what builds them and
what gets in their way
uh
we found that we could discover the
causation of the positive states the
relationship between
uh left hemispheric activity and right
hemispheric activity as a
cause
of happiness
i've spent my life working on extremely
miserable people and i've asked the
question how do extremely miserable
people differ from the rest of you
and starting about six years ago we
asked about extremely happy people and
how do they differ from the rest of us
and it turns out there's one way very
surprising they're not more religious
they're not in better shape they don't
have more money they're not better
looking they
don't have more good events and fewer
bad events the one way in which they
differ they're extremely social
they
don't sit in seminars on saturday
morning
they
they don't spend time alone each of them
is in a romantic relationship and each
has a rich repertoire of friends but
watch out here this is merely
correlational data not causal and it's
about happiness in the first hollywood
sense i'm going to talk about happiness
of bullies and giggling and good cheer
and i'm going to suggest to you that's
not nearly enough in just a moment
we found we could begin to look at
interventions over the centuries from
the buddha to tony robbins about 120
interventions have been proposed that
allegedly make people happy
and we find that we've been able to
manualize many of them and we actually
carry out random assignment
efficacy and effectiveness studies that
is which ones actually make people
lastingly happier in a couple of minutes
i'll tell you about some of those
results but the upshot of this is that
the mission
i want psychology to have in addition to
its mission of curing the mentally ill
in addition to its mission of making
miserable people less miserable is can
psychology actually make people happier
and to ask that question happy is not a
word i use very much
we've had to break it down into what i
think is askable about happy and i
believe there are three different
and i call them different because
different interventions build them it's
possible to have one rather than the
other three different happy lives the
first happy life
is the pleasant life this is a life in
which you have as much positive emotion
as you possibly can
and the skills to amplify it the second
is a life of engagement a life in your
work your parenting your love your
leisure time stops for you
that's what aristotle was talking about
and third the meaningful life so i want
to say a little bit about each of those
lives and what we know about them
the first life is the pleasant life and
it's simply as best we we can find it
it's having as many of the pleasures as
you can as much positive emotion as you
can
and
learning the skills savoring mindfulness
that amplify them that stretch them over
time and space
but the pleasant life has three
drawbacks and it's why positive
psychology is not happy ology and why it
doesn't end here
the first drawback
is that it turns out the pleasant life
your experience of positive emotion
is
heritable
fifty percent heritable and in fact
not very modifiable so the different
tricks that
matu and i and others know about
increasing the amount of positive
emotion in your life
are 15 to 20 percent
tricks getting more of it
second is that the positive emotion
uh habituates it habituates
uh rapidly indeed it's all like french
vanilla ice cream the first taste is a
hundred percent by the time you're down
to the sixth taste it's gone
and
as i said it's not
particularly malleable
and this leads to the second life i have
to say about my friend len
to talk about
why positive psychology is more than
positive emotion more than building
pleasure in two of the three great
arenas of life by the time lynn was 30
len was enormously successful
the
first arena
was work by the time he was 20 he's an
options trader by the time he was 25 he
was a multi-millionaire in the head of
an options trading company
second in play he's a national champion
bridge player
and uh uh
but in the third great arena of life
love len is an abysmal failure and the
reason he was
was that len is a cold fish
uh len is an introvert
uh
american women said to len when he dated
them you're no fun you don't have
positive emotion get lost
and uh len was wealthy enough to be able
to afford a park avenue psychoanalyst
who for five years tried to find the
sexual trauma that had somehow locked
positive emotion inside of him but it
turned out there wasn't any sexual
trauma it turned out that
lane grew up in long island he played
football and watched football and
played bridge
len is in the bottom five percent of
what we call positive affectivities the
question is is len unhappy
and i want to say not contrary to what
psychology told us about
the bottom 50 of the human race and
positive
i think len is one of the happiest
people i know he's not consigned to the
hell of unhappiness and that's because
len
like most of you
are is enormously capable of flow when
he walks onto the floor of the american
exchange at 9 30 in the morning
time stops for him and it stops till the
closing bell when the first card is
played till 10 days later the tournament
is over time stops for when
and this is indeed what
mike sent me high has been talking about
about flow and it's distinct from
pleasure in a very important way
pleasure has raw feels you know it's
happening
it's thought and feeling but what mike
told you yesterday during flow
you can't feel anything
you're one with the music
time stops you have intense
concentration and this is indeed the
characteristic of what we think of as
the good life
and we think there's a recipe for it and
it's knowing what your highest strengths
are and again there's a valid test of
what your
five highest strengths are and then
re-crafting your life
to use them as much as you possibly can
recrafting your work your love your play
your friendship your parenting just one
example
one person i worked with was a bagger at
gennardi's
hated the job she's working her way
through college
her highest strength was social
intelligence
so she recrafted bagging
to make the encounter with her the
social highlight of every customer's day
now obviously she failed but what she
did was to take her highest strengths
and re-craft work to use them as much as
possible
what you get out of that is not
smiliness you don't look like debbie
reynolds you don't giggle a lot what you
get is more absorption
so that's the second path the first path
positive emotion the second path is
eudaimonia and flow and the third path
is meaning this is the most venerable of
all the happinesses uh traditionally and
meaning in this view consists of uh very
parallel to eudaimonia it consists of
knowing what your highest strengths are
and using them
to belong to and in the service of
something larger than you are
well i mentioned that for all three
kinds of lives
the pleasant life the good life the
meaningful life
people are now hard at work on the
question are there things that lastingly
change those
lives and
the answer seems to be yes and i'll just
give you some samples of it
it's being done in a rigorous manner
it's being the done in the same way that
we test drugs to see what really works
so we do random assignment
placebo-controlled
long-term studies of different
interventions and just to sample the
kind of interventions that we find have
an effect
when we teach people about the pleasant
life how to have more pleasure in your
life
one of your assignments is to take the
mindfulness skills
the savoring skills and you're assigned
to design a beautiful day
next saturday set a day aside design
yourself a beautiful day and use
savoring and mindfulness to enhance
those pleasures and we can show in that
way that the pleasant life is enhanced
visit
i want you all to do this with me now if
you would close your eyes
i'd like you to
remember
someone
who did something enormously important
that changed your life in the
good direction who you never properly
thanked
person has to be alive
okay
now
okay you can open your eyes i hope all
of you have such a person
your assignment when you're learning the
gratitude visit
is to write a 300 word testimonial to
that person
call them on the phone in phoenix
ask if you can visit don't tell them why
show up at their door
you read the testimonial everyone weeps
when this happens
and what happens is when we test people
one week later a month later three
months later they're both happier and
less depressed
another example is a strength state in
which we get couples to identify their
highest strengths on the strengths test
and then to design an evening in which
they both use their strengths and we
find this is a strengthener of
relationships
and fun versus philanthropy but it's so
heartening to be in a group like this in
which so many of you have turned your
lives to philanthropy well my
undergraduates and the people i work
with haven't discovered this so we
actually have people do something
altruistic
uh and do something fun
and to contrast it and what you find is
when you do something fun it has a
square wave walk set when you do
something philanthropic to help another
person
it lasts and it lasts
so those are examples of positive
interventions
so the next to last thing i want to say
is
we're interested in how much life
satisfaction people have this is really
what you're about
and that's our target variable and we
ask the question as a function of the
three different lives how much life
satisfaction do you get
so we ask and we've done this in 15
replications involving
thousands of people to what extent does
the pursuit of pleasure the pursuit of
positive emotion
the pleasant life the pursuit of
engagement
time stopping for you and the pursuit of
meaning contribute to life satisfaction
and our results surprised us they were
backward of what we thought it turns out
the pursuit of pleasure has almost no
contribution to life satisfaction the
pursuit of meaning is the strongest and
the pr and this is the pursuit of
engagement is also very strong
where pleasure matters is if you have
both engagement and you have meaning
then pleasure is the whipped cream and
the cherry which is to say
the
full life the sum is greater than than
the parts if you've got all three
conversely if you have none of the three
the empty life the sum is less than the
parts and what we're asking now is does
the very same relationship
physical health morbidity how long you
live
and productivity follow the same
relationship that is in a corporation
is
productivity a function of positive
emotion engagement and meaning is health
a function of positive engagement of
pleasure and of meaning in life and
there is reason to think the answer to
both of those may well be yes
so chris said that
the last speaker had a chance to
try to integrate what he heard and so
this was amazing for me i've never been
in a gathering like this
i've never seen speakers stretch beyond
themselves so much which is one of the
remarkable things
but i found that the problems of
psychology seem to be parallel to the
problems of technology
entertainment and design
in the following way we all know that
technology entertainment and design have
been and can be used
for
destructive purposes
we also know that technology
entertainment and design
can be
used to relieve misery
and by the way the distinction between
relieving misery and building happiness
is extremely important
i thought when i first became a
therapist 30 years ago
that if i could make someone
if i was good enough to make someone not
depressed not
anxious not angry
that i'd make them happy
and i never found that i found the best
you could ever do was to get to zero
that they were empty and it turns out
the skills of happiness
the skills of
the pleasant life the skills of
engagement the skills of meaning are
different from the skills of relieving
misery
and so the parallel thing
holds with technology
entertainment and design i believe
that is it is possible
for these three drivers of our world
to increase happiness
to increase positive emotion and that's
typically how they've been used but once
you fractionate happiness the way i do
not just positive emotion that's not
nearly enough
there's flow in life and there's meaning
in life as laura lee told us design and
i believe entertainment and technology
can be used to increase
meaning engagement in life as well so in
conclusion
the 11th reason for optimism in addition
to
to the space elevator is that i think
with technology entertainment and design
we can actually increase
the amount of tonnage of human happiness
on the planet
and if technology
can in the next decade or two
increase the pleasant life the good life
and the meaningful life
it will be good enough if entertainment
can be diverted to also increase
positive emotion
meaning
eudaimonia it will be good enough and if
design
can increase positive emotion
eudaimonia and flow and meaning
what we're all doing together will
become good enough
thank you
[Applause]
you